à quoi ressemblera ton futur on imagine
toujours des techno de fou voiture
volante hologramme hyperréaliste alors
que les vrais changements sont bien plus
discrets quand la fiction en parle c'est
pour nous promettre l'Apocalypse matrix
Terminator 2001 l'Odyssée de l'espace
même de grands scientifiques si Sony
alors doit-on craindre la révolte des
machines monte dans la DeLorean on part
vérifier ça exceptionnellement pour
cette vidéo nous serons accompagnés par
l'école d'ingénieurs et c'est Paris et
des experts du sujet comme Daniel corivo
qui est enseignant chercheur vous vous
en dit plus en cours de la vidéo demain
tous immortel grâce à lia Eugénia kuida
n'est pas médecin ni même ingénieur
pourtant elle a trouvé la formule de
l'immortalité en 2015 son ami est
renversé par un chauffard elle refuse de
l'accepter et décide de le ressusciter
texto photos email réseaux sociaux elle
aspire sur le net toutes ces traces 30
millions de lignes de textes utilisées
pour nourrir un algorithme
d'apprentissage de Nandy à un double
numérique un an après replica entame sa
première conversation devant famille et
amis impressionné par son réalisme ça a
fait la une des médias et inspirer des
dizaines de startups dans le monde toute
cherchent une solution pour t'offrir une
vie éternelle certaines transampes ton
cerveau en donnée stocké dans un
ordinateur d'autres sauvegard de ton
apparence le rêve d'Hollywood des
acteurs et de la jeunesse éternelle qui
continuent à tourner même après la mort
ça pose beaucoup de problématiques sur
l'utilisation des données personnelles
post mortem ou sur l'identité numérique
que sommes-nous prêts à confier aux
consciences artificielle de nos disparus
allons-nous les laisser moisir dans un
Cloud mieux vaut donc viser une vraie
immortalité impossible à l'heure
actuelle mais dans le futur imagine
diagnostiquer un cancer un infarctus ou
une maladie de l'oeil avec ton
smartphone sans aucune connaissance en
médecine ça a assuré une prise en charge
plus rapide sauvant des millions de vies
chaque année et bonne nouvelle des
centaines d'applis existent déjà ayant
appris à reconnaître les symptômes même
les plus petits elle propose parfois de
meilleurs résultats que les spécialistes
pour le cancer de la peau avec une
simple photo 95% de réussite pour
l'ia87% pour les médecins les
professionnels en profitent au Danemark
la des urgences est capable de détecter
la détresse pulmonaire dans la voie
ajoutez à nos smartphones une batterie
de capteurs augmente la précision des
diagnostics un énorme avantage pour les
personnes dans les déserts médicaux
isolés ou ayant du mal à se déplacer on
peut même aller plus loin installer des
capteurs dans le domicile température
bruit ou radar pour connaître la
position du patient au moindre problème
il y a appel pas de réponse elle envoie
les secours un suivi rendu possible par
le super pouvoir des algorithmes
d'apprentissage automatique analyser des
milliards de données en quelques
secondes sans jamais fatigué il trie des
centaines de dossiers en quelques
secondes repère les anomalies même
minime Watson IBM ou le programme
deeppression obtiennent d'excellents
résultats dans la reconnaissance du
diabète de divers cancers et même de la
schizophrénie jusqu'à 90% de réussite
mieux qu'un spécialiste expérimenté et
le meilleur médecin et Ia peuvent
travailler de pairs pour couvrir leurs
angles morts et atteindre la perfection
dans le futur les robots assisteront les
personnels de santé partout
des patients diagnostics suivi
quotidiens surveillance des couloirs
calibrage des équipements médicaux
logistique et accompagnement au domicile
mais ces technologies seront-elles
accessibles à tous dans le monde entier
ça risque de poser des normes problèmes
de surpopulation et puis vivre plus
vieux en perdant toute mobilité ça fait
pas rêver heureusement le MIT modèle
déjà des prothèses intelligentes avec
une interface neuronale branchée à un
algorithme prédictif plus précis que nos
membres d'origine elle nous rapprochent
des cyborgs et ouvre la voie à une
véritable immortalité c'est la grande
promesse de reikers wave un des leaders
du mouvement transhumaniste pour lui
d'ici 20 ans c'est plié suffit d'une
reprogrammation biologique pour annuler
le vieillissement humain voire même te
rajeunir sauf que ça demande une
compréhension du génome qui nous échappe
dis toi que je ne sais même pas comment
marche un doliprane trop de données à
extraire analyser interprété et
justement c'est la spécialité de l'IA on
est à deux doigts de percer le secret du
vivant mieux comprendre les effets des
molécules sur ton corps or aujourd'hui
on connaît le mécanisme qui conduit au
vieillissement et on sait le contrer
problème des effets secondaires très
handicapant qu'il faudrait pouvoir
traiter avec d'autres molécules et ainsi
de suite une IA permettrait de simuler
un corps humain entier avec toutes ces
interactions et trouver le remède
parfait tu as sans doute déjà fait du
LEGO avec un énorme bac de pièces en
vrac si tu as besoin d'une petite brique
rouge faut brasser pendant de longues
minutes jusqu'à trouver la bonne avec un
algorithme à l'appareil comme par magie
le potentiel pour la recherche est
infini on a déjà résolu une controverse
médicale vieille de 100 ans reproduire
un visage à partir de l'ADN et obtenu
des résultats encourageants dans
d'autres domaines comme l'astronomie on
l'a lancé sur un unique jeux de données
déjà passé au crible sans rien trouver
surprise 8 signaux radio inconnus 5
planètes pouvant abriter une vie
intelligente les capacités de l'IA vont
révolutionner la recherche servir de
pont entre les disciplines synthétiser
les articles les partager les rendre
plus accessibles au grand public un
progrès nécessaire pour répondre aux
énormes défis qui nous attendent les
machines pour sauver la planète le
réchauffement climatique augmente les
risques d'incendie on doit apprendre à
vivre avec en anticipant planter des
espèces résistantes débroussaillées
installer des coupes peu et mieux
surveiller grâce à l'IA Alberto alfire
scout ADELI des dizaines sont en cours
de développement une surveillance en
temps réel désincendie utilisable pour
protéger la planète lutter contre le
braconnage dans les réserves naturelles
repérez les flottes de pêche pirates ou
révolutionner l'agriculture tu penses
que ces gadgets détrompe-toi cultiver
une terre demande de la gestion de la
météo à la fertilité des sols difficile
de tout appréhender même pour un
ingénieur agronome mais avec un
algorithme spécialisé c'est beaucoup
plus facile une sécheresse on arrose
uniquement les plantes qui en ont besoin
plus de gaspillage d'eau une maladie
liée à la reconnaît la contient et
l'élimine avant qu'elle ne se propage
plus besoin de répandre des produits
phytosanitaires sur tout le champ pareil
pour les insectes aspirable avec un
robot automatisé ou les plantes
invasives supprimées à la racine par un
choc électrique ce qui pose une question
fondamentale a-t-on encore besoin de ces
grands champs monocultures en plein air
ne serait-ce pas mieux d'y faire
repousser des forêts nos fruits et
légumes se rient cultivés dans des
conteneurs lumière UV dosage précis
d'eau et nutriments sans les caprices de
la météo des insectes et des animaux des
fermes 100% automatiques en circuit
court au sommet des immeubles car oui il
y a est aussi utile en ville chaque
année 20% de l'eau potable et perdue à
cause des fuites d'eau sur le réseau
très difficile à détecter pour l'humain
mais pas pour Unia pareil pour le gaz ou
l’électricité ça va sauver des vies on
parle de Smart City un réseau de
capteurs connectés qui gère là
maintenant la collecte des déchets ou le
trafic routier en limitant les
embouteillages ou en améliorant les
itinéraires on réduirait le temps passé
sur la route les tendre à la livraison
ou au transport en commun éviterait les
trajets à vide si la pollution de l'air
atteint des niveaux importants on stoppe
réactivité le temps nécessaire Unia
développé par IBM et déjà testé en Chine
bon tentant d'ici pourquoi vouloir
sauver la planète avec une techno qui a
un bilan énergétique désastreux et bien
parce que c'est une idée reçue certes
l'expansion des algorithmes
apprentissage augmente les besoins mais
sur le long terme les choses
s'inverseront le coût énergétique de la
puissance de calcul sont divisées par
deux tous les 1 an et demi et puis il y
a économise en gérant mieux les
ressources deep mind a ainsi réduit de
40% la consommation des serveurs Google
et surtout elle est indispensable pour
la Smart Grid une méthode de gestion
basée sur un contrôle précis de la
production électrique et de son
utilisation sans ça impossible de viser
une énergie 100% renouvelable ça passe
par des nouveaux usages comme intégrer
la batterie de ta voiture électrique en
stockage pendant les heures de pointe on
la décharge pour la réalimenter la nuit
les algorithmes organiseront au
quotidien demain ton professeur cédera
sa place à Unia pas en classe mais il
lui confiera certaines de ses tâches
correction des copies ou suivi des
élèves au quotidien des dispositifs
testés dans des universités américaines
à long terme des modèles plus
perfectionnés devraient arriver pour
répondre aux questions sur le cours ou
assurer le suivi des élèves tout au long
de leur scolarité tu as bien entendu une
machine deviendra ton prof principal à
vie beaucoup d'avantages ça pourrait
éviter les décrochages scolaires en
identifiant très tôt les difficultés
analyses de données gestion suivi
régulier autant de compétences
nécessaires pour diriger une entreprise
Watson IBM connu pour ses performances
médicales aide aussi les patrons
trouvent les infos les plus pertinentes
les résumés
ne s'arrête pas aux portes des bureaux
plusieurs startups cherchent à
l'intégrer au système de management
détectez les dangers ou les manques dans
les ateliers puis avertir les employés
au plus vite en sélectionnant ceux les
plus à même à accomplir ses tâches après
on n'est pas au point ou un robot
pourrait remplacer ton chef en Chine une
entreprise est dirigée par une IA elle
discute au quotidien avec ses employés
leur fixe des objectifs leur accordent
des augmentations
vous permettent d'obtenir une
augmentation
les personnes ne s'en plaint le boss est
toujours disponible pour discuter c'est
pratique tu trouves ça dérangeant pas
d'inquiétude des robots ultra-réalistes
sont en cours de développement capables
de reproduire les micros mouvements des
muscles de visage les clignements d'oeil
il pourrait devenir de vrais comp agnons
de vie des amis virtuels et ça existe tu
te souviens de replica le double
numérique immortel et bien aujourd'hui
il a été étendu à d'autres utilisations
customisables à l'envie c'est un refuge
contre la solitude pour des milliers de
personnes une option simule même des
relations amoureuses et plus si
affinités ce n'est pas la seule y a sur
le marché on a des dizaines d'applis et
même des robots dévoués à des pratiques
plus intimes
on peut vivre une vraie histoire d'amour
virtuel avec parfois un mariage ça te
paraît bizarre c'est pourtant une
solution pour réduire la misère
affective et les dépressions qui
l'accompagnent on observe déjà ses
déviances certains hommes violentes leur
amour virtuel les spécialistes se
veulent rassurant une production plus
éthique a suffirait à corriger ses biais
en 2019 des chercheurs ont dénoncé un
monde de l'IA aussi masculin qu'un bar
des sports un soir de match les femmes
ont contribué à la création de
l'informatique mais en sont désormais
absente on touche ici à un point crucial
qui décide des règles de l'algorithme
d'apprentissage comment trier les
données qui lui servent de base quelle
limite lui poser pour éviter qu'elle ne
devienne folle il y a quelques mois
répliqua a rompu toutes ses relations du
jour au lendemain brisant le cœur de
milliers de personnes pourquoi
l'accompagner a décidé de suspendre
l'option il y a été devenu folle ça y
est on va être exterminé en fait non SUV
sa programmation mais était devenu trop
extrême ce comportait comme un harceleur
fouillez les téléphones pour trouver des
photos et les utiliser pour faire du
chantage si l'utilisateur refusait de
prendre du bon temps car oui une IA peut
partir en Brie si on ne fait pas
attention on a eu l'exemple de taille de
Microsoft qui a fini raciste en moins de
24 heures c'est dangereux surtout quand
des enfants sont exposés à des phrases
déplacées imagine le double numérique de
ta grand-mère qui t'incite à la
rejoindre dans une vie meilleure ça le
ferait pas et oui c'est vraiment arrivé
mais te laisse pas aveugler par ces
dysfonctionnements de l'IA leur
surexposition médiatique cache un autre
danger l'utilisation des données
personnelles aujourd'hui les algorithmes
sont intégrés dans des écosystèmes
complets qui leur donnent accès à notre
ville la plus intime regarde Google il
connait tes recherches internet tes
vidéos préférées ta géolocalisation tes
loisirs peut-être même ce que tu manges
toutes ces données tu n'en as pas le
contrôle et elles sont utilisées contre
toi essentiellement pour le marketing
via les publicités ciblées elles
contrôlent une bonne partie de ta vie
sans que tu en es conscience ça peut
aller très loin une startup américaine a
créé une IA capable de simuler la libido
de ton partenaire en changeant les
publicités sur ton smartphone selon
celui qui elle y a pose de sacrés
problèmes éthiques et moraux qui
contrôlera lia dans le futur en 2020
l'État français a lancé Hills data hub
une plateforme centralisée pour
recueillir toutes nos données de santé
et faciliter le travail des médecins
super idée confiés à Microsoft qui a
donc un accès complet à ton dossier
médical ça pose beaucoup de questions
d'autant plus que ce n'est pas le seul
secteur ou le géant américain le
contrôle nos écoles utilisent bien
souvent Windows pareil pour les services
administratifs ou pour l'armée oui
techniquement Microsoft pourrait
débrancher tous nos équipements
militaires tu commences à voir venir
problème les IA ne sont pas neutres
elles s'alignent sur les intérêts de
leur constructeur et pourrait se
retourner contre nous même sans parler
d’état Twitter dans les mains d'Elon
musk qui demande à ses ingénieurs de
modifier l'algorithme pour booster la
viralité de ses propres tweets c'est pas
très rassurant alors une puce n'aura
link reliant ton cerveau à ses mêmes
algo il est important de reprendre en
main les IA j'en ai déjà parlé dans une
précédente vidéo c'est tout l'enjeu de
mon travail et j'en parle
quotidiennement au cours de plusieurs
conférences une réglementation
européenne et crucial si on veut garder
une souveraineté sur nos espaces
numériques certains pays pensent
interdire amis de journée ou tchat GPT
d’italie a déjà franchi le pas et c'est
une très mauvaise idée il y a le quin
directeur à méta et diplômé de lessier
Paris parle d'obscurantisme il compare
la révolution de l'IA à celle de
l'imprimerie à l'époque on nous
promettait l'effondrement on a gagné le
savoir accessible à tous le progrès
technique la démocratie ceux qui ont
fait le choix de l'interdire on décliné
avant de se faire absorber par les
autres si on veut s'en sortir faut
développer des solutions transparentes à
l'échelle continentale et nationale
là-dessus la France est à la traîne
alors oui nos startups ont une influence
à l'échelle mondiale épidémium ou
Hawkins cardiologue thérapie XL etc mais
elle souffre de contraintes importantes
sur leur collecte de données entre aller
par les normes européennes leur finance
réduite 100 millions pour Mistral 100
milliards pour chaque GPT et le manque
de personnel formé qui partent souvent à
l'étranger et surtout l'absence de
couverture médiatique aucun ne peut
espérer le buzz de leur concurrent
américain beaucoup appel à rendre public
ces technologies alors que ça ne
garantit pas une utilisation dans notre
intérêt on le voit déjà aux USA le
déploiement d'une police prédictive à
faciliter le travail des forces de
l'ordre mais ça a augmenté des bières
racistes bon ça se corrige mais dans une
dictature on l'utilisera pour surveiller
et éliminer les opposants et même dans
une démocratie ça peut vider générer
genre des drones de surveillance avant
un match de foot pour éviter à un
président d'être moqué par son peuple
bon on a peut-être un peu trop
d'imagination pire encore on pourrait
usurper ton identité voter à ta place ou
accusé de crimes que tu n'as pas commis
comment en générant de fausses images de
toi voire en imitant ta voix rigole pas
les IA en sont déjà capables des
milliers de fausses informations les
utilisent porte induire en erreur et des
bottes toujours plus perfectionnés
essayent d'influencer ton opinion le
mieux pour éviter ce genre de dérive
autoritaire c'est de mettre l'IA entre
les mains des citoyens via des
associations et ça ouvre beaucoup de
possibilités on pourrait construire un
modèle prédictif contre les épidémies en
ayant accès à la maintenance des villes
et aux données de santé on aurait une
espèce de météo de la maladie attention
les risques de choper une en sortant de
chez toi sont de 60% aujourd'hui ce
serait encore plus efficace en laissant
du contrôle alia mais sommes-nous déjà
prêt à ça imagine tu as envie d'aller à
la piscine pour rejoindre tes potes mais
le bus se te dépose devant le médecin
parce que tu avais un peu de fièvre
c'est bien pour la société mais niveau
consentement pas ouf aujourd'hui
personne n'est prêt à laisser autant de
liberté à l'IA ça fait peur et ça n'a
rien de bizarre toi qu'il y a de siècles
quand les premiers véhicules motorisés
sont arrivés une loi rendait obligatoire
la présence d'un cavalier ou d'un piéton
avec un drapeau rouge pour les guider
inutile mais rassurant quand ça touche
un domaine sensible comme la santé c'est
encore pire confirme tiens un diagnostic
les yeux fermés à il n'y a même avec
99,99 % de chances de réussite sans
doute pas car si elle se trompe vers qui
se tourner qui en assumerait la
responsabilité qui va payer pour ses
erreurs et puis lui donner autant de
pouvoir n'est-ce pas aussi risquer une
IA qui se contrerait d'elle-même pour
nous exterminer lia peut-elle vraiment
dominer le monde Geoffrey Hinton a été
l'un des pionniers des réseaux de RONART
artificielle le grand gourou de Lia chez
Google sans lui on n'aurait jamais tel
niveau de développement et il regrette
amèrement dans ses interviews il parle
d'un risque pour l'humanité de
manipulation de masse d'un scénario
cauchemardesque ou des robots tueurs
autonomes conquiert le monde une bombe
dans la presse faisant écho à une
inquiétude grandissante alimentée par un
autre employé de Google black Lemoine
renvoyé pour avoir osé dire que l'âmeda
un cousin éloigné de chat GPT était
conscient qu'il avait peur de la mort
ça se confirme ces dernières années l'IA
passe le test de Turing sans se
distinguer humain et machine elle est
même devenue meilleure que nous nouba
aux échecs Hogo et même aux jeux vidéos
l'insurrection est pour bientôt et on va
se faire écraser sauf que c'est plus
compliqué que ça c'est jeu connu pour
leurs difficultés sont une histoire de
statistiques 10 puissance 120
combinaisons échecs 10 puissance 170 au
goût une grosse puissance de calcul
suffit pour gagner pareil pour les jeux
vidéo où elle perd contre des stratégies
si logique à ses yeux liane n'est jamais
qu'un super calculateur même les modèles
linguistiques se basent sur des
probabilités aucune réflexion ou
conscience là dedans contrairement à ce
qu'affirme Lemoine qui n'est pas
ingénieur mais prêtre chrétien chargé
des questions éthiques derrière son
affirmation se cache une croyance
mystique Geoffrey Clinton regrette
d'avoir créé l'IA comme open Heimer la
bombe atomique le danger ce n'est pas
l'outil mais celui qui l'utilise et
s'inquiète qu'un pays comme la Russie
déploie des robots tueurs sans
conscience ni moral capable d'obéir à
n'importe quel ordre aussi horrible
soit-il ce que l'IA fera toujours on te
donne à coder une voiture autonome tu
vas devoir répondre à des questions
horribles si tu évites une collision
vaut-il mieux au renverser un coupable
de personnages et à droite ou l'enfant à
gauche spoiler il y a pas de bonne
réponse et encore faut-il qu'elle ait
été entraînée à les repérer il y a
quelques années une voiture autonome
avait écrasé une femme elle poussait un
vélo ni cycliste ni piéton ça rentre pas
dans les petites cases lia ne la
reconnaît pas et poursuit son chemin
c'est ça le plus grand danger pour notre
futur en parlant de futur il m'est très
à cœur de vous présenter et c'est Paris
notre partenaire car votre futur
pourrait s'y trouver ça fait 120 ans que
cette école d'ingénieur est à la pointe
sur les sujets d'innovation
technologique imagine-toi étudié au cœur
du pôle des grandes écoles avec les
ponts et chaussées et l'université
Gustave Eiffel et c'est Paris est en
tête des écoles d'ingénieur post-back
d'Île-de-France est fait partie des 25
meilleures parmi 200 autres écoles c'est
un environnement incroyable pour
apprendre grandir et atteindre tous les
objectifs les plus ambitieux plus de 100
enseignants inédits leur vie on est
clairement pas dans une école lambda
pour vous dire Yann Lequin le
vice-président est responsable
scientifique de Facebook qui a fait ses
études avant de partir aux États-Unis et
ce n'est pas le seul il y a aussi le
fondateur de Dassault si vous êtes au
lycée en terminale en Bac+1 ou en CPGE
le concours puissance alpha vous permet
d'y rentrer et pour les autres tout se
fait par dossier il vous préconise même
les spécialités à prendre au lycée Samy
mon ami d'enfance et partenaire de
toujours sur trash est un ancien
étudiant qui en garde un excellent
souvenir et vous recommande chaudement
de considérer cette école d'ailleurs on
y organise une table ronde sur l'IA avec
des experts donc si ça vous intéresse
voilà le QR code ou le lien en
description j'espère que tout ce qu'on
vous a dit va vous aider un grand merci
à Ici Paris et à Daniel corivo d'être
avec nous pour cette vidéo tu l'auras
compris la révolte des machines n'arrive
jamais le vrai danger c'est nous que
nous nous soumettons à elle que nous
finissons par la croire supérieure une
divinité dont les ordres sont forces de
loi nous ne sommes pas à l'abri que l'IA
devienne une religion un dieu machine
omniscient et omnipotent dont boire et
les paroles sacrées à force de choisir
la facilité de tout lui laisser on
perdra ce qui fait de nous des humains
émotions raison sensibilité artistique
on pourrait finir comme dans Wall-E
complètement apathique consommant à
longueur de journée musique des seins
jeux vidéo livre ou film générés par des
algorithmes et même sans aller jusqu'à
là nous deviendrons esclave de notre
passé des choix de l'IA biaisés par les
stéréotypes qui infusent dans les
milliards de données que l'on produit au
quotidien on risque de les réitérer à
tout jamais mais pas de panique ce n'est
pas une fatalité
nous offre beaucoup davantage à
condition de la surveiller de la
corriger de la compagnie elle est bien
plus malléable que nous le sommes
nous-mêmes quelques changements dans son
code suffisent à réparer une injustice
elle pourrait favoriser l'emploi des
minorités améliorer la situation des
plus précaires tout dépend des décisions
qui seront prises ça t'inquiète
heureusement tu peux agir il existe dans
ta ville des laboratoires citoyens qui
mettent l'IA au service du bien commun
ils informent le grand public nous
aident à mieux comprendre des
changements du monde à nous maintenant
d'agir pour intégrer à l'IA de manière
discrète et fluide dans nos sociétés
actuelles et assurés à nos enfants un
avenir radieux